[Musik]
Amerika hat viele Kriege geführt was
macht Interessen aber auch für Freiheit
und Demokratie könnte der Krieg in der
Ukraine wirklich deren Ende bedeuten
die Angst vor dem doomsday dem
Weltuntergang treibt viele um in diesem
Winter kann sich entscheiden wohin wir
gehen ich sage bewusst wir weil
Geschichte wird von Menschen gemacht wir
entscheiden über Krieg oder Frieden auch
darüber ob die Ordnung der Welt wie wir
sie seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg kennen
sich verändert oder ob wir wie im Kalten
Krieg eine Zweiteilung der Welt haben
zwischen liberalen Demokratien und
Autoritarismus es ist ein historischer
Moment und dergleich deinem anderen vor
genau 60 Jahren
[Musik]
als die Sowjetunion 1962 Atomraketen auf
Kuba stationierte da hielt die Welt den
Atem an doch die Entschlossenheit und
die klaren Ansagen der US-Regierung
verhinderten die nukleare Katastrophe
unsere Regierung hat versprochen den
militärischen Aufmarsch der
Sowjetregierung auf Kuba aufs Genaueste
zu beobachten und
die Botschaft das solch ein Krieg keine
Sieger hinterlassen würde konnte Sowjet
Führer kruschev nicht missverstehen
nur weil Amerika hart blieb gab es in
den Jahrzehnten danach keine
vergleichbare Situation keinen Weltkrieg
so meint Historiker Timothy Snyder
wenn Sie einen Atomkrieg
unwahrscheinlicher machen wollen müssen
sie von ihm abschrecken wenn er
wahrscheinlicher werden soll dann müssen
sie der nuklearen Erpressung nachgeben
das lehrt die Erpressers öfter zu tun
und sie bringen potenziellen Diktatoren
mit Atomwaffen bei dass nukleare
Erpressung funktioniert deshalb darf man
in solch einem Fall keine Zugeständnisse
machen denn das macht einen
konventionellen und einen nuklearen
Krieg wahrscheinlicher
diese Lehre aus der Geschichte leitet
auch Joe bei deshalb spricht er nach
Putins atomdrohungen von Armageddon
öffentlich unmissverständlich zur
Abschreckung
ich richte mich direkt an Putin wenn ich
so etwas sage er darf nicht weiter
ungestraft über den Einsatz von
taktischen Atomwaffen reden als wäre so
ein Einsatz rational ein Fehler eine
fehlereinschätzung niemand kann sicher
sein was passiert und das könnte zu
Armageddon führen
deshalb starten wie damals in der
Kuba-Krise täglich U2
Aufklärungsflugzeuge sie sollen die Welt
alarmieren wenn Russlands Atomwaffen
wirklich in Stellung gebracht werden
aber wladimir Putin hat schon erreicht
was er wollte Angst vor breiten viele
Menschen vor allem in Europa und
Deutschland sind bereit ihm nachzugeben
[Applaus]
ausgerechnet Menschen außerhalb des
Schlachtfelds nutzen das Thema um sich
einzureden dass es dabei um sie geht das
verstellt den Blick auf das was den
Krieg tatsächlich zu Ende bringt nämlich
die Ukraine bewaffnen und Sie gewinnen
lassen
selbst die die dem täglichen Terror
ausgesetzt sind lassen wissen dass sie
nach einem Atomschlag noch
entschlossener weiterkämpfen würden
würde man die Ukrainer dann ihrem
Schicksal überlassen auf keinen Fall
meint der ehemalige US-General Ben
hordes es gebe keinen Grund Putin
nachzugeben der Russland durch einen
taktischen Atomschlag in der Welt ja ein
für alle Mal isolieren würde
warum müssen wir also einen Deal mit ihm
machen was ist der zwingende Grund und
ich würde fragen ob sie bereit sind
Schleswig-Holstein aufzugeben oder
überlasst ihm doch Sachsen oder
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern nur um des
Friedens willen
jeder der so denkt hat wirklich ein
märchenhaftes Bild von Wladimir Putin
und von der denke des Kremmen wenn Sie
glauben dass sie sich damit
zufriedengeben nur ein Stück Ukraine zu
behalten
2002 beim Gipfeltreffen zwischen der
Nato und Russland in Rom hatte Wladimir
Putin der Ukraine eigentlich ein
Versprechen gegeben damals ging es um
die Frage ob das Land Mitglied der NATO
werden könnte die Regierung in Kiew
wollte die Nato-Partner zu diesem
Zeitpunkt nicht obwohl Moskau
offenkundig damit kein Problem gehabt
hätte
die Ukraine ist ein unabhängiger
souveränerstaat der über seinen Weg
zufrieden und Sicherheit selbst
entscheidet ich sehe hier nichts
problematisches was einen Schatten auf
die Beziehungen zwischen Russland und
der Ukraine werfen könnte
trotzdem ließ Putin 2014 die Grimm
erobern und Panzer in die Ostukraine
Rollen sowie 2008 schon in Georgien und
Moldawien
2022 war die logische Folge absehbar der
Ukraine Krieg ist Teil einer Kette von
Kriegen deren Ende nicht in Sicht ist
wenn Putin nicht gestoppt wird deshalb
sieht die US-Regierung einen Zwang all
jene Waffen zu liefern die nicht nur die
Niederlage der Ukraine verhindern
sondern sogar einen Sieg gegen Russland
ermöglichen
und dem Pentagon liegen Pläne parat für
eine massive Antwort auf einen
russischen Atomschlag nicht nuklear
sondern konventionell direkte Angriffe
um die russischen Streitkräfte in der
Ukraine kampfunfähig zu machen die
US-Regierung soll Leon paneta ein
CIA-Chef dann Verteidigungsminister
werde wie einst in der Kuba-Krise
entschlossen handeln und offen
kommunizieren
es gibt nur diese Antwort für die
Vereinigten Staaten und die NATO um
Putin klar zu machen dass es dann keine
Einschränkungen bei der Unterstützung
für die Ukraine mehr gibt
und dass er dadurch am Ende besiegt wird
wenn Russland Gewinne würden wir wohl
das kostbarste verlieren an was uns die
Ukrainer erinnern nämlich dass die
Demokratie real ist Menschen schätzen
die Demokratie vor allem auch in Ländern
in denen es sie nicht gibt damit es
Demokratie muss man manchmal Risiken
eingehen
diese Einsicht hält den elitären Club
der G7 zusammen aber Joe Biden wirbt
auch um Unterstützung bei anderen die
die Demokratie für die beste
allergierungsformen halten es geht um
den Erhalt der Liberalen Weltordnung
was immer in diesem Krieg geschieht
verrät uns eine Menge über die Zukunft
der Demokratie im 21 Jahrhundert
es geht darum ob wir einen Tyrannen
stoppen können der eine souveräne
Demokratie übernehmen will das ist eine
sehr wichtige Botschaft an Autokraten in
aller Welt
genau diese Botschaft wollen wir an
China senden in Sachen Taiwan
aber auch an Nordkorea in Bezug auf den
Einsatz von Atomwaffen und die gleiche
Botschaft gilt für den Iran
China übt längst für die Eroberung
Taiwans aber der Ukraine Krieg ist auch
eine Lehrstunde für Peking weil Putins
brutaler Angriffskrieg scheitern könnte
kürzlich signalisierte Ping seinem
russischen Partner erstmals Bedenken am
kosmoskau
ich sehe sie nicht mehr als grenzenlose
Freunde Präsident Cheat zeigt dass die
Freundschaft Grenzen hat er unterstützt
den Kreml nicht und ist glaube ich nicht
glücklich über seinen Freund Wladimir
der die Weltwirtschaft zertrümmert das
schadet auch China
auch der indische Premierminister Modi
ließ Putin wissen die sei nicht die
rechte Zeit für Krieg Indien kauft zwar
weiter eifrig billiges Öl aus Russland
aber sucht seit Monaten die Nähe zur
US-Regierung
beidens neues Wirtschaftsforum in der
indopazifischen Region findet Anklang
weil viele Länder unter dem Eindruck des
Ukraine Krieges Angst vor dem
autoritären China haben
jetzt besonders nachdem Präsident Chi
seine Macht gefestigt hat einmal mehr
droht er mit dem Wiederanschluss
obwohl bei den Vereinten Nationen doch
eine überwältigende Mehrheit von 143
Ländern die russische Annexion
ukrainischer Gebiete verurteilt hat nur
Nordkorea Weißrussland Syrien und
Nicaragua sind noch Erfüllungsgehilfen
Putins
aber unter 35 Staaten die sich enthalten
sind jene die am Ende mit entscheiden ob
Russland isoliert bleibt oder die Welt
langfristig zweigeteilt ist zwischen
Gegnern und Anhängern des Autoritarismus
neben China und Indien fallen besonders
Länder in Afrika auf sie haben einen
anderen Blick auf den Ukraine Krieg wie
sich bei der Herbsttagung von Weltbank
und Internationalem Währungsfonds in
Washington zeigt die Auswirkungen des
Krieges wie steigende Preise Energie-
so mancher hier wirft dem sogenannten
Westen Doppelmoral vor ihr so heißt es
hier gebt der Ukraine Milliarden und
Milliarden das ist auch in Ordnung in
einem Krieg aber wir als
Entwicklungsländer wachten gleichzeitig
immer noch auf die Milliarden die er uns
als corona-hilfen versprochen haben die
Länder des globalen Südens sehen sich
als Opfer der Machtspiele zwischen den
Großmächten und die Vertreter der
reichen Länder haben es hier schwer klar
zu machen dass ein Nahrungsmittel und
inflationskrisen nur einer die Schuld
trägt Vladimir Putin
in zahlreichen Regionen geht es für die
Menschen wie für die Ukraine um das
nackte Überleben
dazu will difficult für Länder mit der
größten Zahl von unterernährten wird es
sehr schwierig die Ärmsten zu beschützen
die Menschen die jetzt schon hungern die
gleichen Länder haben noch viele andere
Probleme viele haben interne Konflikte
sie sind gar nicht in der Lage Maßnahmen
umzusetzen um den Armen zu helfen
auch Länder denen es schon besser ging
erleben Rückschläge seit Jahresbeginn so
die UN ist die Zahl der Hungernden von
282 Millionen auf über 345 Millionen
Menschen angestiegen zum Teil Folge des
Krieges
nur eins scheint positiv die Welt
erkennt ihre Abhängigkeit von Öl und Gas
der Wille zum Wechsel auf erneuerbare
Energien wächst auch wenn es schwer
fällt
dazu auf die ölpreis-krise in den 70er
Jahren folgte ein großer Politikwechsel
weg vom Öl hin zu Atomkraft und Kohle
jetzt befreien wir uns davon der Schock
jetzt wird wie damals vieles verändern
die Geschichte lehrt das aus düstersten
Tagen Gutes entstehen kann amerikanische
und sowjetische Soldaten kämpften für
die Befreiung Europas so konnte
Deutschland das den schrecklichsten
aller Kriege entfesselte zu einer
führende Demokratie werden das
verpflichtet
Ukraine Krieg ist auch ein deutscher
Krieg sogar mehr ein deutscher als ein
amerikanischer ob die deutschen das
Erkennen oder nicht er trifft sie direkt
als die Amerikaner er trifft die
Europäische Union direkter als
Nordamerika deshalb sollte die
Bundesregierung diesen Krieg auch als
ihren ansehen und es offen aussprechen
die Voraussetzung für das Überleben und
den Erfolg eines geopolitischen
europäischen Projekts ist ein
ukrainischer Sieg in diesem Krieg
US-Präsident beiden sieht dem Ukraine
Krieg die Bestätigung seiner These dass
wir uns entscheiden müssen
wir befinden uns erneut in der großen
Schlacht um die Freiheit der Schlacht
zwischen Demokratie und Autokratie
Freiheit und Unterdrückung der rechte
basierten Ordnungen und der die auf
roher Gewalt beruht
die Führungsrolle Amerikas wie der
herzustellen
ich glaube das ist die richtige Rolle
wie nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg müssen
sich die USA der Welt als Führungsmacht
anbieten und was wir jetzt haben mit der
NATO mit unseren Verbündeten und bei den
Vereinten Nationen das ist Ausdruck
dieser Führungsstärke
diese Geschlossenheit wollte Putin
zerstören stattdessen hat er sie durch
seine Aggression zusammengeschweißt und
gestärkt mit neuen Partnern Russlands
Erpressungsversuche laufen ins Leere
das ist der letzte Winter in dem
Russland Gas als Hebel gegen uns
benutzen kann
es ist nicht der letzte Winter in dem
wir uns mit Russland abgeben müssen aber
wenn wir zusammen bleiben dann kommen
wir durch diesen Winter und sind im
nächsten Sommer in einer viel besseren
Lage
natürlich verfolgt Amerika bei aldema
auch seine Machtinteressen aber es geht
eben auch darum Freiheit und Demokratie
zu verteidigen gegen den Autoritarismus
unsere ganze Dokumentation über die
weltweiten Folgen des Ukraine Krieges
könnt ihr in der ZDF Mediathek sehen den
Link findet ihr hier und abonniert bitte
unseren Kanal um keine Folge von winter
is coming zu verpassen